♪ ♪
>> Dana: WE HEAR ABOUT
CELEBRITIES CALLING FOR GUN
CONTROL BUT THEN THEY STARTED
MOVIES THAT PROMINENTLY FEATURE
THEM.
WE HAVE CALLED THEM OUT FOR
THEIR HYPOCRISY AT THIS TABLE
OVER THE YEARS BUT ACTOR ETHAN
HAWKE IS OFFERING SOME
REFRESHING HONESTY ON THE ISSUE.
WATCH.
>> PEOPLE TALKING SO MUCH ABOUT
GUN CONTROL IN THIS COUNTRY.
I NOTICED RECENTLY IF YOU PUT IN
A COLUMN EVERY MOVIE I EVER DID
WHERE I CARRY A GUN AND WHERE I
DON'T AND MY SALARY.
IF I ASKED MY FATHER TO DO THE
MATH ON THIS, I THINK IT WOULD
BE ABOUT 92% TO 8%.
>> Dana: SORRY, I THOUGHT I
WAS GOING TO BE EVEN HAWKE.
IT WAS MIKE BAKER FROM IDAHO.
JUST KIDDING.
OBVIOUSLY THAT WAS ETHAN HAWKE.
IT'S TRUE ABOUT CIGARETTES TOO.
>> Greg: YES.
IF HOLLYWOOD ACTUALLY BELIEVED
IN THEIR CAUSES, THERE WOULD BE
NO GUNS AT ALL.
YOU CAN IMAGINE IN "DIE HARD,"
BRUCE McLEAN FIGHTING
TERRORISTS WITH A PEACE SIGN.
I HAVE AN IDEA.
THEY SHOULD APPLY GUN-CONTROL TO
MOVIE GUNS.
THE ONLY WAY YOU CAN DO THIS IS
TAX MOVIES BY AMOUNTS OF GUNS
AND BY THE AMOUNT OF BULLETS
THEY USE FOR MOVIES.
HOLLYWOOD'S GUN-CONTROL
ACTIVISTS, AND THERE ARE LOTS OF
THEM, WILL THEY BE OKAY FOR A
GUN-CONTROL TAX ON MOVIES WITH
GUNS?
TAX THE BULLETS.
$10,000 EVERY TIME THERE IS A
BULLET.
$100,000 FOR A GUN.
WOULD THEY DO IT?
SOMEBODY SHOULD INTRODUCE APPLE
TOMORROW.
I AM FULL OF IDEAS.
>> Dana: THAT IS A GOOD IDEA.
WHAT ETHAN HAWKE IS SAYING THAT
IN MOVIES WHERE THERE IS GUNS HE
GETS PAID 92% MORE THAN IF HE
DIDN'T HAVE A GUN IN A MOVIE.
HE WOULD GET PAID ABOUT 8% OF
HIS USUAL.
>> Jesse: HOLLYWOOD MADE
MILLIONS OFF HIS GUNS.
ALL OF THE ACTION MOVIES IN THE
'80 ZEN '.
DIE-HARD, ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER,
EVERYONE HAS A GUN.
>> Greg: QUENTIN TARANTINO.
>> Jesse: ALL OF THAT STUFF
MADE OF FORTUNE FOR THE STUDIOS.
THEN COME AROUND AND SAY YOU
WANT TO TAKE AWAY GUNS FROM
LAW-ABIDING AMERICANS.
IT'S A LITTLE HYPOCRITICAL.
I WANTED TO BRING SOMETHING TO
YOUR ATTENTION.
THIS HAPPENED YESTERDAY.
THERE WAS A SCHOOL SHOOTING, A
19-YEAR-OLD BROUGHT A GUN AND
STARTED OPENING FIRE IN A SCHOOL
IN ILLINOIS AND AN ARMED
RESOURCE OFFICER SHOT HIM,
NEUTRALIZED THEM, DIDN'T KILL
HIM.
SAVED COUNTLESS LIVES.
THAT STORY WAS NOT COVERED
ANYWHERE IN THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
ANYWHERE IN THE MAINSTREAM MEDI
MEDIA.
>> Greg: I WAS GOING TO DO IT
TOMORROW IN THE MONOLOGUE.
>> Juan: AN EXCEPTION TO THE
RULE.
>> Greg: SO IT IS THE RULE.
>> Juan: HERE'S THE THING.
WHEN PEOPLE COMPLAIN ABOUT
SMOKING IN MOVIES, IT HAD AN
IMPACT.
WHEN PEOPLE COMPLAINED --
>> Dana: THEY STILL DO IT.
>> Juan: THEY DO IT MUCH LAST.
YOU THINK ABOUT HOW GAYS WERE
DEMONIZED IN MOVIES, NOW IT'S
NOT AN ISSUE.
MORE BLACK ACTORS UP FOR
COMPETITION IN LEEDS AND BIG
MOVIES.
IT DOES MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
TO SAY GUNS HAVE MADE MONEY FOR
HOLLYWOOD, IN THE WAY, IT SEEMS
TO ME, IT ENCOURAGES THEIR
CULTURE.
I GO TO THINGS LIKE GUNSMOKE,
JOHN WAYNE, INDEPENDENT,
SELF-SUFFICIENT AMERICAN MALE.
BUT I WONDER IF AT SOME POINT IT
WOULDN'T BE, WE CAN HAVE A
DISCUSSION ABOUT IT.
JUST BECAUSE IT'S GUNS DOESN'T
MEAN YOU CAN'T DISCUSS IT.
>> Greg: WHEN YOU SAY GUNS
ENCOURAGE THE CULTURE, WHAT DO
YOU MEAN?
>> Juan: THEY REFLECT.
THEY SHAPE THE CULTURE.
IF YOU ARE A GUY AND YOU SAY I'M
GOING TO HAVE A GUN.
I AM A REAL MAN.
BY THE WAY, I SAW HEAR MORE
PARENTS SAY AS LONG AS THE
VIOLENCE IS JUSTIFIED AND LIKE
SELF-DEFENSE WHEN THEY DON'T
MIND SEEING GUNS IN MOVIES.
>> Jedediah: SOMETIMES WHEN
PEOPLE WATCH TELEVISION AND
MOVIES, THEY JUST WANT TO BE
ENTERTAINED.
I THINK ABOUT THIS EFFORT THAT
COULD SANITIZE THESE THINGS,
LET'S REMOVE THE VIOLENCE AND
LET'S ONLY HAVE IT -- THAT IS
NOT WHAT FILM AND TELEVISION
SHOULD BE.
SOME OF MY FAVORITE MOVIES.
I LOVE LIAM NEESON.
I LOVE HIM IN THE TAKEN MOVIES.
SOME OF THESE THINGS RELY ON
THAT STORY LINE.
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO HAVE A
CHASE OR YOU ARE HUNTING DOWN A
KILLER AND YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
NO GUN.
IT'S INTEGRAL TO THAT.
I DON'T THINK, IT'S THE SAME
ARGUMENT PEOPLE MAKE, OH, GREW
UP PLAYING VIOLENT VIDEO GAMES,
YOU'RE GOING TO BE VIOLENT.
IT DOESN'T WORK THAT WAY.
>> Jesse: SO YOU ARE AGAINST
GREG'S TAX PLANTED TAXI BULLETS.
>> Greg: I WANT TO SEE THE
GUN-CONTROL ACTIVISTS IN
HOLLYWOOD ACCEPT THAT PLAN.
>> Dana: IT'S TRUE THAT IF YOU
READ AS A YOUNGSTER, JESSE.
I >> Jesse: I DON'T LIKE THIS